la multinacional johnson y johnson que
participa en el desarrollo de la vacuna
contra el joven 19 reanuda el envío de
dosis a europa luego de una pausa por la
presencia de coágulos de sangre en un
grupo de personas inoculadas en eeuu la
luz verde la dio el comité de seguridad
de la agencia europea del medicamento
ema al asegurar que dichos trombos son
efectos secundarios muy raros de la
vacuna de manera que incluirán dicha
información en las etiquetas
lo que queremos es asegurarnos de que
las personas tengan los hechos y la
información para tomar medidas sobre los
efectos secundarios graves posibles y
raros
pero debo enfatizar nuevamente que son
muy raros
y que en la gran mayoría de los casos
estas vacunas evitarán muertes y
hospitalizaciones debido al cob y 19
si la agencia europea del medicamento
examinó en días pasados que de las 7
millones de personas que han recibido la
inyección única de johnson y johnson en
eeuu
sólo se han presentado ocho casos de
coagulación en adultos menores de 60
años dentro de las tres semanas
posteriores a la inoculación
af ópticas es después de una revisión
cuidadosa de los casos de coágulos de
sangre combinados con el bajo nivel de
plaquetas informado después de la
vacunación con la vacuna
covite 19 de janssen el prat ha
concluido que existe un posible vínculo
entre la aparición de estos coágulos de
sangre combinados con los niveles bajos
de plaquetas sanguíneas y la inoculación
con la vacuna combina 19 jan sin jams la
farmacéutica estadounidense espera
reactivar el envío de 200 millones de
dosis de la vacuna a la unión europea
noruega e islandia mientras que las
autoridades europeas aseguran que con
esta dosis única el balance entre
beneficio y riesgo sigue siendo positivo